They not voting.
They not voting because they don't trust you
politicians.
They don't voting because they don't trust
that you will deliver on your promises.
So why is it that a young person
who's 24 years old
listening to this conversation,
why must they vote for you?
Why must they make you president of the republic?
Well, I'm happy that you raised that point.
Because the youth don't see politics working for them.
So the first thing you do
is to make sure that politics work for the youth.
And once they see the politics working for them,
they will come in their numbers.
Look at what we did
at the institutions of high learning
when we took over their services.
We said the budget
which is spent on fragilesbourne festivals
must be cut by 70%.
That 70% must go and feed
the needy students at the universities.
They used to spend millions at universities
doing baches with the S R C. Money.
We cut that
and we give the poor lunch and supper
from the money that was supposed to organise festivals.
What happened?
The youth then realised that
in the Institutes of Albany
that this thing is working for us.
As a result,
there is a mood all over universities
of educated people,
not illiterate
educated people,
who say we want to make an educated vote.
And that vote is for the E F A.
Because we can see that politics are working for us
in the Insurance of Albany.
Let's make the politics to work for our people.
What will you do?
I'll give them the land.
I'll give them access to education
free of charge.
I will beneficiate the minerals of South Africa
and industrialise the economy of South Africa
so that we're not an economy of consumers,
we're an economy of people
who produce
manufacturing.
Or to be revived in South Africa
if were to create sustainable jobs.
I will end load shedding in less than no time.
Because load shedding is man made.
When there is World Cup,
there is no load shedding.
When children write exam,
there is load shedding.
Have you ever seen such madness in life?
Where we must switch on the lights to see Rugby
and then switch off the lights
when the children are writing an exam?
What type of load shedding are we dealing with?
It has got eyes and ears.
It knows that Kolisi is about to
pick up the ball.
It doesn't go
when Kolisi finishes,
then it goes.
It goes with the World Cup.
It's man made.
Is created to empower. Cyril.
Cyril, Cyril and.
And the air.
Cyril Ramaphosa
made load shedding? Yes. How?
Because they want to empower the I P p's.
They don't maintain the cold power stations,
they close cold power stations.
Because the biggest problem
at the centre
of what we're dealing with here
is the maintenance of our power stations.
That's why they tell you
unit 1 is collabs.
Unit 3, Is collabs.
There is nothing magical
that Brian Malefer did
and Martellogogo did.
All they did
was to make sure they maintain, er,
the. Our own
power stations.
They close this one,
they know if we close this one for two days,
it will be up
before you know it.
We go to the next one.
There's general
no maintenance
and corruption
is eaten away.
Er, that er. Eskom.
What do they do?
They then say, no,
let's load shed.
So that we create a crisis.
When we introduce independent power producers,
our people are gonna say, yoh,
maybe there is a solution here.
Let's go with independent power producers.
Who is independent power producers
is RAM Group.
Who owns RAM Group
is Johann Rupert.
You are now going to be given electricity
by Johann Rupert.
I mean this crisis.
Faith. I mean,
let's go to Prasa. Look,
there's no long distance trains.
From November last year
until today,
the people of Limpopo used to occupy that train
full to Capacit.
Eastern Cape.
Full to Capacit.
They rent locomotives,
put them there
and then do not give them to people.
And then they say,
we spend 600 million,
this locomotives only gave us 10 million.
Then we all say, hi.
No, it means
it's a waste of money.
That's why we can't spend 600 million
only to get 10 million.
No, they didn't
use their locomotives.
They hired with 600 million,
put them there
and create an imaginary crisis
so that when they come and Say,
let's outsource this thing to our.
To our friends.
People should say hi.
No, maybe we'll get trains,
because we've not been getting trains.
All of this is a fact
under the president
Ramaphosa, who said
he's going to be corrupt free.
He's going to be transparent.
He's going to do lifestyle audit on ministers.
He's going to crack the whip on corruption.
This government
has become the most corrupt government
that switches off lights
for children
who are writing matric exams.
Let me take higher